[Musique]
salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle vidéo alors on va
regarder aujourd'hui une partie qui
s'est jouée entre ordinateurs au chess
computer championship et qui a opposé
komodo donc moteur d'analysé a bien
connu dans le milieu avec ses fameuses
morsure contre winter alors là je ne
connais pas vraiment il est censé être
moins fort que komodo mais comme lobo il
à un flocon donc le flocon contre le
commodo est ce que quand le commodo mort
le flocon sadien de l'eau c'est là qu'on
va le découvrir ensemble est resté
jusqu'à la fin de la partie puisqu'ils
un joli sac fils de dames qui vaut le
coup donc les blancs ouvre par eux
quatre winter qui répondent eux cinq
cavaliers trois attaques le pion aux 5
et winter qui joue la défense petrov
cavalli apsys qui contre attaque
e4 komodo qui s'empare du pion e5 est
ici winter ne tombe pas dans le piège
cavaliers pro 4 sur lequel il y aurait
dames deux attaques lecavalier et si
lecavalier s'en va on va pouvoir
effectuer une découverte par cavalier c6
qui attaquent le roi avec la dame et
attaque la dame donc ça gagnerait du
matériel
et si on veut maintenir après terme de
lecavalier en vie par des saints qui va
y avoir des 3 et les blancs vont gagner
du matériel allez on retourne vers la
partie après cavaliers six cavaliers
prendre 5
les noirs ont joué donc des six en
premier pour attaquer le cavaliere cinq
cavaliers 3 est maintenant cavalier
prend à eux quatre ce qui va permettre
sur dame 2 de jouer dams est comme ya
plus de cavaliers en jeu 5
le cavalier e 4 serait protégé alors ici
à les blancs ont joué des 4 et les noirs
ont répondu des 5
donc on a une position symétrique sauf
que les noirs ont entre guillemets
gagner un tempo par camaïeu quatre dons
qu'ils ont comme c'est comme s'il avait
joué ce qu'avait lieu 4 mais ce cavalier
qui va pas forcément être super bien
placé pas ce qui va se faire attaquer
alors je dis pas forcément super bien
mais tout ça est théorique et ça et ça
se jouait donc c'est bon juste pour
montrer si on veut avoir la position
avec lecavalier en abscisse après
cavaliers pro 4 avec les noirs on peut
jouer avec les blancs des trois
cavaliers axis d4 d5 et là on a une
position complètement symétrique qui
transposera d'ailleurs dans une
française devant des changes c'est aux
blancs de jouer sauf que là le carrier
pendant le 4
les blancs jouerait pas cavalier c'est
d'ailleurs ici peu importe
du coup qu'elle provoqua des quatre des
cinq donc il prend le choix de mettre ce
qu'a réalisé sur quatre pour s'en
prendre à lui fout des trois les noirs
jouent fawcett petit rock donc les
blancs près partout revin pour attaquer
le cavalier alors ici le grand coup
théorique ces cavaliers c6 qui a été
analysée sur analysé le coût de la
partie ça va être cavaliers des six avec
éventuellement l'envi de jouer fouet f5
on va quand même regarder ce qui se
passerait sur petit rock admettons un
développement normal tours 1
j'attaque le cavalier fouet pts 5 je le
maintiens envie c 4 j'attaque le socle
c6 je protège le socle dame ces deux je
m'en prends un peu à la diagonale
cavaliers 17 cavaliers c3 j'augmente la
pression sur le cavalier cavalli tf6
donc c'est une bande pour illustrer ce
qui se passe si les noirs s'accroche à
ce qu'avait lieu 4 et maintenant
cavalier e 5 pour les blancs et ça
commence à être problématique pourquoi
parce que ce cavalier e 4 il est un peu
sous pression on peut pas le bouger
pascal fouet f5 en l'air derrière et
avec les blancs j'ai l'idée de faire f3
et de gagner une pièce sur découvert
donc par exemple sur admettons food et 6
on va faire f3 et on va gagner la pièce
donc on semble se cavagnan le maintien
en vie mais ça va pas être facile la
forêt peut-être joué fou j'ai six
meilleurs avec l'étrange ici ce qui
traîne on est autre et c'est un peu
mieux pour les blancs donc après petit
rock comme je vous disais calisesi c'est
le coût théorique le plus joué ici la
jica et des six avec l'idée
éventuellement de mettre le fou en f5
les blancs qui joue tout re 1 donc il se
place sur la colonne e petit rock et c3
consolide le pion des 4 et prépare le
développement est aussi père mais autre
chose on valoir tout de suite sur france
donc ce serait un peu l'idée de
développement à des noirs pour contrer
le rayonnement à 2 se fout il y aurait
foot pro f 5 cavaliers price 5 et dames
b3 très pénible s'en prend aux pions 17
admettons b6 et maintenant tour 500
prend aux pions des 5 et au cavalier
donc le flou f5 pas vraiment jouable
dans cette position dans la partie il a
décidé de jouer car il est 17 donc ils
retardent le développement du fou comme
ça ça lui blanc
2 le pion bessette sa prémunit un peu
con que les dames b3 les blancs qui
sortent leur fou en f4 tour 8es cavale
et b d2 je crois qu'on est dans une
position symétrique à la structure de
pions et complètement symétrique pas
encore le pion ans et 6 mai peut y venir
à n'importe quel moment on voit en tout
cas que l'on à 4 contre 4 allèles dames
et trois contre trois allaient droit et
dans ses positions complètement
symétrique
évidemment ce qui va être important
c'est l'activité des pièces jusqu'à pas
un joueur ou l'autre qui est une
meilleure structure de pions et
l'activité des pièces ici elle est
supérieure aux blancs pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont toutes les
pièces sorties déjà alors que les noirs
on se fout c'est 8 un peu bloquée ils
ont poussé trois en plus ce qui permet
d'avoir les dames b3 qui surveille et du
coup ils vont pouvoir éventuellement
être les premiers à frapper avec un
cavalier a eu 5 qui viendrait à être un
bel avant postes puisque les noirs
auraient plus de mal à le chasser on
voit fou détroit mieux que le flou cette
fois f4 mieux que le foot c'est 8 et les
cavaliers prêt à bondir un peu mieux que
les cavaliers noirs
alors si on joue par exemple fouet fuite
pour essayer d'échanger les pièces le
long de la colonne ne les tours en tout
cas ce qu on pourrait se dire que sans
tour ce serait plus facile à jouer mais
les bleus en fait ils peuvent en échange
et une part tout reprend 1,8 dame prend
huit dames ces deux ils se placeraient
il attaquerait le pion à acheter
on pourrait le défendent éventuellement
par g6 pour préparer fou g7 mais la tour
arrive en lin et on voit que les blancs
ont forcément un avantage un toutes les
pièces sorties et comme je disais fous
ces huit tours à huit qui ont un peu de
mal
paris va y avoir dan des 8 et on va
essayer avec les noirs petit à petit de
de se développer de et d'aller chercher
le nul mais évidemment c'est plus
agréable pour les blancs on va avoir des
plans là cavalier afin qu'ils aient g 3h
4h 5 pour attaquer et à et le quai
équipes arrivant au 5
enfin avantage blanc donc sur cavalli bd
de il veut pas échanger ses tours il a
joué cavalier f8
alors il tente de se développer en
kabylie qui peut rejaillir vers 6hoo
verger 6 et s'adonne l'espace aux foules
et blanc qui joue cavalier f1 les noirs
qui blindent le pion des cinq par ces
six ça anticipe des attaques à venir
à noter que fouet f5 et toujours pas
jouable cette fois ci à cause de fou
prend des 6 et surtout prendre des trois
il faut prendre cette attaque la dame
donc cavalier f1 il a joué ces six et
maintenant le cavalier qui jaillit en e3
et on voit que les blancs prennent le
contrôle des cases du fou petit à petit
casef cinq cases g4 contrôler et ils
vont pouvoir jouer des dames ces deux
tours de tours e1 et continuer à
augmenter la pression les noirs qui joue
cavalier g6 bien jouer s'en prend aux
fouets f4 fou g3 est ici va jouer
cavalier e 4 alors sur un développement
normal il va revenir 1 manon qui
contrôle un peu mieux la case de 4 et
que lecavalier troyes aube ce prix va
revenir dessus
alors juste sur un développement normal
à la fouille si je vais passer vite dame
ces deux dames 17 donc on essaye de
développer avec les noirs on va faire h4
avec les blancs commencent à prendre de
l'espace
admettons torah dès 8h cinq cavaliers
fuite
donc on sent que c'est l'activité pour
les pièces blanches ail blanc vont
continuer par b trois fois 6 et 4
essayer de monter petit à petit leur
position pour prendre de l'espace au
noir et les mettre sous pression donc
sur fou g3 il a décidé de ne pas rentrer
dans ces positions un peu désagréable à
long terme
il a joué cavalier 4 il revient avec son
cavalier au centre et s'en prend aux
fous j'ai trois les blancs jouent ces
quatre pour commencer à miner le pion c
est ici honnêtement je ne comprends pas
trop pourquoi alors c'est la cadence et
une plus un plus un donc les ordinateurs
sont pas forcément à leur meilleur
niveau
c'est une cadence courte mais ok je
pense que si tu viens au caire 4 qui est
rangé 3 pressé un algorithme n'ya rien à
comprendre mais un aller au moins
apprendre le flou pendant ces 4 pourquoi
pas mettre le foin f8 essayer de
préparer vous aussi ça je comprend 1
qu'il a du rappeur d'un truc comme ça
font peur et encore c'est un gros mot
avec de l'activité pour les blancs mais
au moins on a quand même pris la paire
de fois avec les noirs et si on réussit
à faire b 6 rue cisson va s'en sortir
après évidemment joue pas contre un être
humain donc tu auras pas d'erreurs mais
disons que ça m'aurait semblé plus
logique de continuer là dedans parce que
sur ces 4 il n'a pas les prendre en g3
il a fait fougue et 4 il s'en prend à la
tour dont la tour bouge en e2 fou aussi
ce développement est maintenant puis on
prend des 5
donc oui on prend des 5 avec sûrement
l'idée qu'il va y avoir c'est prend des
5 et dames b3 donc attaque le fou s'en
prend un peu à des cinq bons à cinq et
ma foi dans les blancs sont bien on va
pouvoir jouer peut-être avec des à trois
avec des tours ces deux tours c'est un
jouet la colonne s'est il ya un bel
avantage blanc mais bon pour apprendre
un jour en g3 et ça va dans la partie
refaire un choix étonnant il prend du
food qui donne la paire de fou fou prend
des 5 et prend des cinq dames prend des
cinq pour créer le pion isolé alors
c'est vrai qu'à première vue ça peut
être alléchant mais là les blancs et
comodo baril va super bien joué il va
jouer fouet cinq ici vraiment un très
bon coup à il coupe la connexion de la
tour avec le cavaliere 4 donc les noirs
qui prennent une fois aux 5 prend la
paire de fou cavaliers pour le 5
réattaque lecavalier 4 et cavaliers des
six et il se dit ok je tiens le pion à
vii qui peut être important et je tiens
à la casse ces quatre comme ça il n'y a
pas de poussée 4 mais il ya deux
problèmes je dirais avec avec les noirs
il ya déjà le problème des cases
blanches qui sont quand même faible et
on sent qu'avec tour 3 damage cinq tours
h3 ça peut aller très vite en l'espace
de trois coups on peut avoir quasiment
toutes les pièces blanches sur le roi
s'allier avec le fait que le fou des six
est obstruée par le câble le fou bekkat
obstrué par le cavalier des six il a du
mal à revenir
et ce cavalier des six il est bien placé
pour bloquer cette diagonale là mais il
n'est pas forcément bien placé si on se
ramène avec la dame et la tour pour
attaquer âge c'est tout g7 donc on sent
que ça peut être dur hélas komodo va a
joué de manière très précise et très
forte
il va faire pousser deux avec l'idée de
mettre le fou en b3 éventuellement ou de
libérer dam des trois les noirs qui
continue partout ras des huit fini son
développement mais la pression sur le
plan des quatre fous b3 attaque la dame
on ne peut pas aller en a cinq nous on
pourrait peut-être revenir ans et 7 ça
paraît plus harmonieux à cause de a3 et
le fou est enfermé contrôler toutes les
cases du fou donc sur four b3 les noirs
n'ont qu'une case réellement pour la
dame c'est la case b5
mais c'est vrai on sent que c'est papa
très harmonieux la la dame peut parvenir
à les couper aussi du retour les blancs
qui font tour 3 et la winter qui va
péter un plomb
parce que l'attak de mater et
instoppable on va juste voir comment il
a fini ce que cette menace là il peut
pas il peut pas l'empêcher
il l'a fait damas 5 bon alors là il y
aurait à trois essais gagnera la pièce
jusqu'au bout les winter voile attaques
de maths et il ne sait pas quoi faire
damages 5 menace fou prend fc à tous car
il y prend un s est donc tours 7
et ici si vous souhaitez vous pouvez
mettre sur pause et voir comment komodo
a fait la morsure fatale à aux flocons
de neige
il a joué d'un proche des fêtes or on
apprend h7 tourage trois échecs roi g8
et cavaliers g6 clouage du pion à vii et
aux menaces tourache huit matchs donc à
une superbe combinaison de maths
effectué par komodo et victoire donc des
blancs ici dans une belle partie
intéressante pédagogiquement avec une
belle feinte le tournage suit imparable
bah je trouve très élégant
personnellement merci d'avoir suivi la
partie jusqu'ici n'hésitez pas à mettre
1 pouces bleus si vous n'avez plus à
vous abonner à la chaîne chaise comme
france ciao ciao
[Musique]